why do I always have black against him
holger b3 I cannot stand it anymore
every game really absolutely every game
he plays that stuff amazing if so what
to do now him after f5 we get some kind
of drop offs key it's a some way to play
on the dark square cm and these if
someone is so absolutely insisting on a
particular thing like like here's you
have this tendency to try and to punish
him for that and it's not really
possible because b3 is not bad but
sometimes you just yeah you just want
too much and this is the thing then they
get get a good musician and I'm
surprised that he allowed me that age 5
business I don't think that I would have
allowed it if I were white in this
situation I mean not that what I'm doing
is so dangerous but just on principle I
wouldn't try to avoid that wow he's
playing like like this is the the
biggest nonsense ever what I'm trying
maybe it is maybe it is ok I think I
have to stop a six at least for the time
being
cetera is that that that ridiculous okay
I'm trying trying for that kind of
attack here so I have to be a consistent
putting the Queen on h2 and then see
what happens check so let's have a look
Lucas on b7
and there are a couple of violent things
that you can definitely try but i think
i have to keep stuff for the moment we
will soon i have three
okay out for F for now
cannot also bring a night over to e4 hmm
all-rookie 686 can an additional hook in
there he played that exceptionally
quickly oh you can take f5 maybe maybe
you can take a five okay I wanted to do
that anyway he has stuff like rooty 725
that's kind of annoying but how to how
to avoid now ma'am that's pretty obvious
that is got that so what do I do now
night here probably and check I couldn't
take on the seven so how to hear how to
do that here okay seven four you get six
or something like that
ah
yeah what is probably winning but maybe
I still have some ideas cannot take you
for unfortunately it's close
how on earth did you play that quickly
he's usually totally slow I mean like
really slow probably had that stuff on
the board a million times well I have no
counter play ray Queen that is just
stuck so it's pretty a pretty awful time
morning and I can even play Bishop g5
well then what a bad game
check sure I don't think you will allow
up the one that would be kind of crazy
95 95 probably wins check I can trade
Queens shoot it was that that's the end
of it I had basically if we can trade
Queens and I mean it was winning anyway
but even the faintest hopes are gone
after a cream trade can teach you seven
it isn't it doesn't matter it was just
lost anyway man alright so for I know it
plays it cool y know what what you have
to be kidding me game continues check
check
I am NOT threatening anything he has a
bishop on g2 idiot such an idiot I
should just take take a five it's made
him his check meeting me is checkmating
me what a terrible game what a terrible
game black resigns oh my god why can you
not just win simply and just doing that
chan and the worst part is so totally
winning for him Chad this is of course a
complete win and the sea pawn will will
just promote chair that kind of a tech
is probably just not good i mean it's
it's yeah yeah it's not not clear maybe
I should probably prefer bishop CA it to
that that this kind of sacrifices is an
issue it really is according next
coordination is some severely hampered
and check this is just not not good it's
just not good it gets taller pawns and t
Scott got some kind of attempt going
check and check kill him down to the
Queen trade it is completely losing yeah
I don't know I'm always a bit bored
against this bb3 stuff maybe I should
just go in five play the best line over
and over and over every game but that is
so boring yeah so should still do that
and punish
probably this is not the way to do it
okay thanks for watching